the man behind it came where's mr. Musa  and he has given us the green light we  are now gonna go for this it's not gonna  be me  this is different so I'm gonna hopefully  is beneficial for all browsers and  difference if you feel free to watch the  video okay so prove it we spoke you know  we said first bra the bra I said the  music's not permissible Amy says  permissible I don't know make up your  mind all right now moving on first I  said Bravo I love you fencing over I  love you I love the problem with mr.  youtubers you know there's a pattern you  know future - boom happen sorry they  always start with unchallenged or on  experiment then they move on you know  another do music videos with kills you  know I didn't even watch the video I  didn't watch the video but I see you  know on the phone naked girls you know  kissing kissing in the next room why  can't I bother freezes cheap same thing  you know brothers you know